rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
découvrir la première partie du sentier
littoral de saint philippe de la pointe
de la marde arzul aux pays arabes
là
rendez-vous au sud de saint philippe à
la pointe de la marde arzul un parking
est aménagé au départ du sentier
littoral
nous y retrouvons teddy avril
accompagnateurs en montagne
bon
depuis le 4 mai chant progresser jusqu'à
saint philippe nécessite souvent de
tracer son propre chemin en bord de
falaise
pour continuer de découvrir le littoral
après saint philippe le cheminement est
plus confortable un sentier a été
aménagé notamment pour traverser une
réserve biologique
géré par lohan f les réserves
biologiques sont une dizaine à la
réunion et celle de saint philippe et la
seule située sur le littoral
la zone que nous traversons aujourd'hui
est donc l'une des portions du littoral
les plus préservés de nous
au fond nous
et ce jour là ce sont plutôt les
rencontres animal qui nous ont marqués
notamment avec des bernard l'hermite
dont un en particulier qui s'était
débarrassé de sa coquille
sans doute voulait-il a quitté pourront
trouver une plus grande plus loin on a
pu se rendre compte de la taille que
pouvaient atteindre justement certains
spécimens
celui ci était suffisamment gros pour
occuper la copie d'une à katyn drôle de
rencontre
quelques avants bords de chemins ont
aussi retenu notre attention comme ceux
beaubois de chandelle
ou plus loin ce spécimen de pistaches
arbustes un exotique dont on a pu à la
fois observer les fleurs et les fruits
mais aussi les jeunes plants
le coc du spectacle c'est cet instant
rare où une dizaine de jeunes tang ont
traversé le sentier juste sous nos pieds
en sortant des sous bois il est parfois
possible d'aller en bord de falaise
notamment pour jeter un oeil aux
souffleurs
le sentier continue d'alterner entre
différentes ambiances traversée de
ravine pourrait de vacoa et pour finir
un cheminement le long des coulées
volcaniques pour rejoindre le parking du
puy arabe
c'est ici que notre randonnée se termine
sur ce site où l'on peut découvrir ce
fameux puits dont on a longtemps cru
qu'il avait été bâti par des navigateurs
arabes avant la colonisation de l'île en
particulier à cause de sa technique de
construction semblable à celle employée
en orient mais tout compte fait il
serait l'oeuvre de européen au début du
19e siècle
cette randonnée
elle est vraiment magnifique c'est un
parcours très varié au départ de saint
philippe
on traverse la réserve biologique du
littoral et on découvre en fait à la
fois le bord de mer qui est composé de
falaise et puis aussi une forêt un peu à
l'intérieur qui est très intéressante où
on a encore beaucoup d'espèces indigènes
donc quelque chose une biodiversité
encore
préservez très intéressant ce niveau là
ce sentier étant donné que là on est sur
la réserve biologique
il est très bien entretenu il ya
toujours un balisage bleu qu'on peut
suivre le sentier assez large
alors il est parfois il faut le chercher
un petit peu mais globalement on est
quand même sur un sentier qui est très
bien entretenu et on peut pas vraiment
se perdre au niveau pratique sur ce
sentier évidemment on peut faire l'aller
retour
mais on peut aussi laisser une voiture
au niveau du parking du puy arabe et
puis faire juste un aller simple
c'est un sentier qui peut aussi se faire
en famille on peut emmener les enfants
c'est c'est assez aisée
évidemment à l'arrivée au parking depuis
arabe l'on peut imaginer un pique nique
la soul et sous les kiosques ce cette
randonnée par contre il faut un peu se
méfier étant donné que la végétation est
dense en marche souvent sur les feuilles
de va quoi notamment on voit pas
forcément le sol et on peut parfois
mettre le pied dans une fissure ou dans
un parfois mais dans un trou donc restez
toujours bien sur les sentiers pour
éviter d'avoir des mauvaises surprises à
ce niveau là